les pays baltes brandissent la soi
disant menace russe dans bien des
domaines
mais pour les autorités russes il existe
une répression cette fois bien réelle
celle des droits des journalistes dans
ces pays un communiqué du ministère des
affaires étrangères publié ce mercredi
fait le point sur la situation et
s'inquiètent des derniers faits en date
2019 le parlement lituanien a bloqué
l'accès au site d'informations russe
foot nique et expulser son rédacteur en
chef depuis un an les employés de
spoutnik estonie ne peuvent plus
travailler sous peine de poursuites
pénales et enfin en lettonie le 3
décembre dernier cet employé de spoutnik
ainsi que d'un autre média en langue
russe baltes news ont été arrêtés une
situation préoccupante décrite justement
par l'ancien rédacteur en chef de ce
site internet devenu assistant
parlementaire n'aurait pas tué mais il
est précis donné ce sont de toute
évidence des méthodes répressives qui
nuit' la liberté des médias
imaginez une situation où par exemple
l'un des dirigeants d'une entreprise
publique occidentale par exemple la bbc
dit quelque chose de négatif au sujet de
la russie la russie l'inclure est alors
dans une liste de sanctions après des
poursuites pénales seraient alors
engagées contre tous ceux qui coopèrent
avec la bbc
tous ceux qui prêtent leurs locaux à la
bbc voilà la logique avec ce qu'elle
estime être des atteintes à la liberté
d'expression et à la liberté d'informer
la russie craint que les voix qui
contestent le message dominant soit
maintenant systématiquement visés
et ce débat prend tout son sens alors
que la liberté d'expression
et ces derniers temps largement remise
en question et ce dans le monde entier